Speaker 1: We have been told I'm not going
to spend a lot of time on this next story,
but I do want to follow up because people ask
me, David, what's going on with those complaints
against Marjorie Taylor Greene? We've said before
radical Trumpist Republican Congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor Greene has been accused and it has been
investigated. There has been an investigation
going on as to whether she illegally spent
campaign funds. There is unaccounted for
campaign money. There are now two different
ethics complaints that we have learned about
that accuse Marjorie Taylor Greene of unethical
and illegal campaign spending. Progressive
watchdog group and Citizens United filed two
ethics complaints against Marjorie Taylor Greene.
She's accused of unethical and illegal
spending by her Save America Stop
Socialism leadership PAC. One complaint
was filed with the House's ethics body,
which has already fined her three times for not
wearing a mask. She is facing these accusations,
according to two ethics complaints. The group
filed a complaint with both the FEC and the Office
of Congressional Ethics, both of which focus on
a recent ad where she urges supporters to call
members of Congress and ask them to oppose
the one trillion dollar infrastructure bill
passed by the Senate last month. The group's FEC
complaint alleges that Greene Save America Stop
Socialism Leadership PAC made an unreported
in-kind contribution to her own campaign
by running a nearly identical version of the ad
on O.N, and that the contribution well exceeded
the $5000 limit legally permitted. Many members
of Congress have so-called leadership PACs,
which are nominally for raising money for other
candidates, but they have become slush funds
by ethics advocates, so that's one complaint.
Meanwhile, the complaint with the House Ethics
body says she improperly used her campaign
and leadership PAC to conduct official house
activities because the ad constitutes a grassroots
lobbying campaign to oppose legislation.
You know, I'm glad that this is going on. I
really am. And like, of course, we know that
Marjorie Taylor Greene is doing sketchy stuff with
campaign funding and various political sources
of money. But is there ever really going to be
punishment? I mean, remember, we covered the story
of Marjorie Taylor Greene taking to homestead
exemptions, making to homestead declarations,
which is not legal in Georgia. She did that. She
has it on two properties. Whatever happened with
it, nothing. Nothing that I was able to find as
of this morning. Ethics complaints, what comes
of those other than the ethics office filing it?
I mean, I really don't know. Now, technically,
these complaints could lead to expulsion basically
never happens like expulsions from the house,
not related to the Civil War. I believe it's,
you know, it's under-5 that I think it might
be two or three that have ever happened.
So unfortunately, even though the list of
concerns about the behavior of Marjorie
Taylor Greene ethically and legally continues
to rise. The real solution is voting her out.
She's in a very red district. It doesn't look
like it's going to happen. It's horrifying. I'm
with you. It's completely dystopian, but it is
just not looking good. And the best path forward
is to continue maybe growing democratic control of
the house in 2022, as unlikely as that might seem.
And what can be done? Censure. She's already been
stripped of committee assignments. I really don't
know. It's actually one of the most frustrating
aspects of American government right now
that there seems to be very little in the way
of serious ways to hold people accountable.